Hello everyone. Today we'll go over the
step-by-step instructions to add an
additional key fob using this pro keybox
kit. This kit is compatible with 2008 to
2013 BMW 1 series compatibility guide at
the end of this video. This kit comes
with the original key fob and the
programmer tool. If you have your own
unprogrammed remote, you can also
purchase the programmer tool separately
as an alternative option. So to begin
the process, you need to connect the
tool to the OBD board.
Select key program, then press okay.
Choose cast 3, then press okay.
Choose keyless,
then press okay. Press push to start
ignition once,
then press okay on the programmer tool.
Press okay again.
Choose learn key from the menu. Then
press okay.
Now press push to start ignition once.
Press okay. Choose status free then
press okay.
Press exit. Then press push to start
ignition once.
Then press okay.
The programmer will start reading your
vehicle data.
Here
you need to choose your key type. Remote
key for keys without comfort access and
keyless go for keys with comfort access.
Then press okay.
Put the new key in the white coil slot.
Now press push to start ignition once.
Then press okay and wait for programming
to finish.
Great. Programming successful. Insert
the key into the vehicle key slot and
start the engine.
[Music]
Shut the engine off. Then remove the key
and the programmer tool.
In order for the remote functions to
work, open driver door, then start the
engine for a few seconds. Then shut the
engine off and remove the key and close
the driver door. Then test the remote
buttons.
[Music]
Here we can see it's working and it's
all good to go. Hope you enjoyed the
video. Thank you for watching.